Ciao Gu, la mia credenza imbarazzante me la sono
creata da sola. Dopo aver visto un
episodio di "Esplorando il corpo umano"
sulla gravidanza e la nascita
mi ero convinta che il bambino nascesse
dallo spazio fra le tette
Se le tette ce le hai!
Se non hai le tette non puoi avere figli.
Infatti molti uomini a volte, diciamo un
pochino sovrappeso, possono partorire
secondo questa teoria. Maurizio Costanzo
voleva un figlio da Maria de Filippi,
ma lei non glie l'ha dato, solo che a lui
nasceva dallo spazio tra il mento e lo sterno
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
Vita Buttata. Il tema della puntata di oggi è
"Da piccolo credevo che"
E per un tema così importante ho pensato di
invitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia una ragazza che come me si è
persa in quella brutta parentesi che,
diciamo divide "Eskere"da "Buongiorno
caffè, un like per Gesù". Sto parlando di
Silvia dei Trentenni. Già che mi ha chiamato
ragazza va benissimo. Ma no ma ormai anche io devo essere "ragazza", perché sennò guarda che siamo
f*****i in due secondi. Pure te eskere! (Gianmarco) Eskere cosa ho detto? Eskére. Eskére? Beh è
più slang eskére. Però scusami, scusami... Ah tu hai detto eskere? Si
Scusa perché stai ridendo? Perché tu lo usi sempre? Sempre! Ho imparato...
Ma tu, scusate, voi usate "eskére" nella vita?
"No però lo usano in questo modo" (Gianmarco) non è le
Non è "Let's get it?"Ah è vero, perché, è vero, quindi eskére. Guarda quasi quasi preferisco "Un like per
Gesù". Iniziamo a sentire, poi vediamo che
cosa esce e da lì troviamo ispirazione
Ciao Gu, niente mi madre da piccola
dopo aver visto Toy Story mi faceva
credere che i pupazzi la notte facevano i
festini e li trovavoo la mattina dopo
spostati. Era lei che si svegliava la
notte per spostarli. Io non avrei dormito
No questa è bella. A me mia madre una
volta mi aveva detto tipo che esistono
davvero dai nani, che tipo sai quando non
trovi una cosa, poi ti giri e dici "Ma cavoli!"
Era lì. Sono i piccoli nani che vengono
e ti fanno gli scherzi. Ok non lo
dire mai a tuo figlio.... Da bambino
credevo che i cani si accoppiassero con i
gatti, quindi i cani fossero degli uomini,
invece i gatti fossero delle donne e
scoprire che in realtà era tutt'altro
non è stato facile. Questa male male eh
Vabbè poi nasceva o un gatto o un cane. O Occhi di Gatto
Va bene, possiamo chiudere e possiamo andarcene. Scusate non
posso farne a meno di citare sempre cose che conosciamo solo noi
Se state guardando questo video e non
conoscete Occhi di Gatto potete
chiuderlo, anzi no scrivete...no cosa devono scrivere! Come puoi saper
scrivere se non conosci Occhi di Gatto. No infatti sei troppo piccolo... Tu hai gatti o cani o cose così? No sono
allergica. Immagina se c'era qui il mio cane. L'ho preso tra l'altro l'antistaminico stamattina per sicurezza
Perché suo padre le ha detto
"Cosa vai fare a Roma?No vado, vado da questo
ragazzo molto, poi vi spiego, un ragazzo
molto bravo. Ah ma cosa fa?" Gli spiego cosa
fa. "Come vai lì? Eh mi vengono a prendere
perché gli ho detto "come faccio ad arriavare"
Fa "No no non ti preoccupare ti recupero io"
"Ah, stai attenta!"
Giampaolo guarda, io le chiedo perdono,
perché sono andati a prenderla mio
cugino e mio fratello, cioè nel senso
tu hai visto invece che una Limousine
nera con un uomo brizzolato in livrea
hai visto du scappati di casa che
guidavano un bidone dell'umido. Io gli ho detto "mi
raccomando ragazzi. Subito "Quanti anni
hai? Sei sposata? Ma perché ti chiami i Trentenni?
E poi tra dieci anni sono quaranta?" Si si e quando è entrata in macchina ha fatto "Ah auguri" e boom
Esatto, stavo per dire che poi gli ho menato. Il messaggio del padre era "Digli di stare attenti!"
Mia madre tra l'altro mi ha detto "Ma vai
da sola? Forse la Stefi ci raggiunge
Speriamo! Ecco perché mi hai detto "Ci aggiunge anche la Stefi. Guglielmo guarda, ci
raggiungerà anche la Stefi. Ma dove sei?" Io "Molto fuori dal centro"
E oggi poi scherzando ti ho pure detto "Beh
sai in realtà noi facciamo del baiting
e uccidiamo le persone come Hostel".
Grazie per il defollow. Chi è, ragazzi cosa
sta succedendo. Chi è che sta flertando? Ah è il mio? Vabbè
mettete in silenzioso il mio telefono?
Una delle cose per cui ero più convinta da
ragazzina erano sicuramente quei fili
della corrente che avevano quelle palle al
centro e che io ero convinta che fossero
le pokeball dei Pokemon
Spero di non essere l'unica ma credo di
no. Io pensavo fossero Voltorb in realtà
che sono i Pokemon, cioè li dovevi
catturare. Quindi è tutta colpa vostra il
Pokemon go, il gioco. Allora tu hai già
detto pokemon e colpa insieme, e tu già
capisci che stiamo incominciando ad
allontanarci. No si hai ragione però qui
si sentono quei quattro anni di distanza. No perché quando sono usciti
i pokemon, il primo io avrò avuto 12 anni. Eh
io però ne avevo 16 eh. Ma un sedicenne
cioè ma chissenefrega della f**a, tutta la vita i pokemon
Forse sì hai ragione, solo che io ero già
un po' punkabbestia, un po'...dovevi troppo farti
notare da quelli ancora più grandi. Si bravo.
Adesso invece che cosa facciamo? Andiamo
fuori dalle scuole, dai licei nella
speranza che fuori dalle università
col cosino per il  metallo, hai presente? Ciao Gu ciao ospite, io ho un
fratello,
siccome sono la maggiore gli raccontavo
sempre che era stato adottato anche se
non era vero. Un giorno di risposta mi
disse che c'era uno squalo che poteva
uscire fuori dal water in qualsiasi
momento e non andai più in bagno.
Dovettero anche portarmi all'ospedale
perché io avevo paura che dal cesso potesse
uscire un enorme squalo e farmi non so cosa
Io non a questi livelli che non
vado più in bagno però ancora un po' il
terrore che qualcosa esca, e mi è
successa una cosa. A un certo punto mi
sono alzata, ho finito, ho guardato dentro il water e c'era
una cimice, che equivale più o meno allo
squalo. Beh si. Quindi tu sei stata
tutto il tempo con una cimice sottovuoto
che poteva da un momento all'altro. No ma anche solo appoggiarsi sulla gamba. Perché vuoi essere delicato
sulla gamba. Si sto cercando comunque di
mantenerlo friendly. Perché sei venuto
adesso? Perché parlava di adozione, voi mi
avete fatto credere fino all'altro giorno
io fossi stato adottato, pezzi di m***a!... Enrico, ma è vero
Ops. Non c'ha niente di te eh. E' vero, io sono quello
simpatico e bello infatti... e buono e
generoso. Esatto. Io sono la matrigna
cattiva
Beh a me hanno sempre detto per esempio
quando ero piccolo che io ero un
bastardo. Hai presente John Snow? Certo. Concepito
prima del matrimonio e quindi
automaticamente uno Snow. E tu ci hai creduto e quindi... uno Snorlax in tema Pokemon
Ricordo che quando ero piccola dissi a mia madre che avrei voluto tanto avere la febbre in modo da non andare
a scuola il giorno dopo. Mia madre allora mi disse di non dire queste cose perché se
fosse passato un angelo mentre io dicevo
questa cosa, mi avrebbe fatto avverare il desiderio
e quindi sarei stata male. Da lì ho
sempre avuto paura di dire determinate
cose, ad esempio quando mi arrabbio con una
persona vai a dire tipo "Ammazzati voglio che
tu muoia" o queste cose qui insomma.
Ciao. Beh Genny Savastano, grazie mille cioè
grazie a tua madre, perché sennò diresti "Spero
che tu muoia!", eh? Biv? Che cos'è?
Molto noti gli angeli assassini. Se gli
angeli dovessero avverare tutti i
desideri che ho detto a voce alta dovrei
avere la metà dei miei nemici al
cimitero e soprattutto vivere in una
villa nel Colosseo
Non so te eh poi. Si idem forse, sarei
molto più alta, molto più magra e molto
più alta, magra. Ma guarda che la cosa bella del web è che in realtà è tutto finto. Infatti io sono alta e magra
Hai una ciglia. Ce stai a provà?
Ok era una ciglia
con mascara. Beh tipico commento di
uno che ci sta per provare "Tesoro era una
ciglia con mascara, pazza"
Allora io ho due esperienze, una
è di una mia amica. Quando partiva la
ruota della fortuna e tutti applaudivano
e dicevano ecco a voi
Iva Zanicchi, lei pensava che i Vazzanicchi fossero le persone del pubblico che
applaudivano. Sono chiamate così, come un
popolo "I Vazzanicchi"
L'altra cosa la pensavo io, che il bancomat
fosse una banca che fosse impazzita e
appunto banco mat, che ti desse soldi
gratis. Meravigliose queste. Cioè i Vazzanicchi sono
stupendi, il bancomat che ti regala
soldi. Che bello! Dai che passa l'angelo
il bancomat che regala soldi. Buongiorno Guglielmo, io da bambina credevo che
i cammelli vivessero su Marte, ero convintissima, e una volta lo dissi anche a
mia madre proprio convinta e lei mi fa "Claudia ma come!". Mi crollò un mondo addosso. Quindi le donne vengona da
Venere i cammelli vengono da Marte.
Io da piccola credevo che sai i boschi
un insieme di alberi piazzati lì belli
simmetrici. Ok ho già paura. E' proprio quella cosa lì
Io credevo che nascessero perfetti così.
Mi han detto "Silvia ma guarda che li piantano
così". Ho detto da piccola ma in realtà era tre o quattro anni fa. Ma davvero? Si. Ma aspetta tu parli
di quelli che chiaramente sono stati
piantati da qualcuno? Eh. Ma gli alberi non
sono almeno tanto alti poi. Nono sono altissimi. Aspetta da che
prospettiva sono altissimi? Dalla mia. Non
volevo prendere in giro tutti quante
le persone basse del mondo, alla fine è
solamente un numero...o a tutti quelli che
pensano che i boschi...No ragazzi
forse voi un pochino lo meritate. Ragazzi Silvia dei
Trentenni dovevate prendere alla stazione.
Questa qui ha un appuntamento secondo me
non lo so dal terapista, da chi dovevi
andare tu oggi scusami? Silvia dei
Trentenni, il trio di ragazze, le
assomiglia ma questo è sequestro di persona
ragazzi. Nono devo mandare però un
messaggio per sapere che cosa sta
facendo questa mia amica alla stazione
da tre ore. Quando ero piccina ero
super ossessionata da Sailor Moon e ho due sorelle più grandi. Ovviamente
mi prendevano sempre in giro e una cosa
che mi è rimasta impressa di quello che
mi dicevano è che Sailor Moon in realtà si
chiamava Lormoon e basta, perché la
sigla diceva "sei Lormoon". Insieme ai Vazzanicchi...che insieme ai Vazzanicchi prendono secondo me la
medaglia per incapacità di comprendere
le canzoni. Che in realtà è Lord. Esatto
"Sai Lord Moon". Non ci sto! Non si può
prendere in giro una persona per Sailor
Moon ragazzi...soprattutto se sei sorella
più grande
Io non ci credo che sei sano se prendi
in giro per Sailor Moon quando i tuoi
cartoni erano David Gnomo. David Gnomo? Ma chi è David Gnomo? "David Gnomo, David amico mio.
Dai era uno gnomo col cappello rosso enorme e andava in giro per i boschi. La morale è "Non puoi
permetterti di prendere in giro tua
sorella che guarda Sailor Moon se sei
cresciuta con David Gnomo". Fondamentalmente si. Ciao Guglielmo, io quando ero
piccola prendevo tutti i miei pupazzi e
quando andavo a letto li mettevo vicino
a me, sotto le coperte con la faccia
rivolta verso l'esterno ovviamente
perché sennò avevo paura che soffocassero
e lo facevo ogni sera e se non dovevo
farlo perché mi annoiava mi sentivo
in colpa e pensavo che morissero di
freddo e che potevano morire di freddo e
poi ce l'avessero con me. Di conseguenza per
tantissimo tempo ho fatto questa cosa,
tuttora me ne pento perché non avevo
spazio nemmeno per muovervi. E vabbè, ciao un bacione. Immaginati come tratta gli amici. Ti prego no
prendi la mia giacca, no ti prego prendi la mia maglietta, no ma fa freddo, ti prego no prendi
Mia nonna, in buona fede però in modo
traumatico, da piccola mi diceva che se
mangiamo due banane o più, sarei morta.
In più per convincermi a non prendere le
cose da terra mi diceva che se avessi preso
qualcosa da terra avrei preso il tetano e
sarei morta. A me è venuto il ciclo a 10 anni,
sempre mia nonna mi ha detto che se
facevo la doccia con l'acqua calda mi
sarebbe venuta un' emorragia e sarei morta
Sua nonna veramente il modo migliore proprio per allontanare...per insegnarle un sacco di cose. Ma ha più
senso però. Non tipo "Non prenderlo che sennò l'uomo nero, non prenderlo. Perché? Perché muori!
Queste sono le vecchie nonne di una volta, questa è l'educazione italiana. Perché nonna? Perché muori
Fine, non è che devi aggiungere altro
In pratica un giorno avrò avuto 5/6 anni, ero imperterrito attaccato al
letto matrimoniale dei miei genitori e loro volevano farmi andare via
mi minacciarono dicendo che se non me ne
fossi andato si sarebbero levati la
fede, e io non capendo rimasi.
Poi mio padre mi spiegò che se si fosse levato
la fede io sarei scomparso nel nulla dalla memoria di tutti
Inutile dirti che sono corso a letto e ho dormito prima di subito, Io non avrei dormito mai più, nella vita
Un terrore ragazzi, "Se mi tolgo la fede tu
scomparirai dal mondo e dalla memoria di tutti
Ma sai quante persone dovrebbero
scomparire? Madre santa! Terribile
Ma questa qui è tipo la nonna "Muori". Vattene via! Perché? Sennò muori
E' sempre quello. Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine questo
video. Silvia io ti ringrazio ancora di
cuore per per esserti così prestata
a questa cosa. Ti ringrazio anche per aver
rischiato ecco, la vita
Ringrazio te per avermi fatto vivere
questo brivido di essere recuperata da due
scappati di casa, di essermi fidata, averci creduto fino
in fondo perché mi sono divertita molto
Il problema è il ritorno infatti non è
l'andata, ricordatelo sempre. Come sempre
vi invito a farmi sapere qua sotto quali
sono state le vostre esperienze legate
al tema ma soprattutto quali sono altri
temi che mi piacerebbe vedere
all'interno di questa rubrica, se avete dei
suggerimenti visto che io ho zero
personalità e zero inventiva in questo
momento storico della mia vita.
Vi invito a iscrivervi al mio canale
al canale di Silvia, I Trentenni, che vi
metto tutto quanto in infobox, e che dire
Ciao... ciao  Gu, grazie ciao a voi. Ah alla prossima settimana. Vabbè sti c***i